now to present the award for film  editing is one of the best edited girls  I know  cut to exactly the right length and I  defy any critic to say she doesn't have  a beginning a middle and an end the  beautiful miss Barbara rush  Elbert Hubbard the great American author  and himself an editor wants to find an  editor as a man whose business it is to  separate the wheat from the chaff and to  see that the chaff is printed in  Hollywood the film editors job is to  separate the wheat from the corn those  dominated for best achievement in film  editing are Louis R Leffler for anatomy  of a murder  Ralphie winters and John Dee Dunning for  Ben Hur George Thomason II were North by  Northwest Walter Thompson for the nuns  story and Frederick Newton for on the  beach the winner is Ben Hur Ralphie  winters and John Dean  my humble thanks to everybody thank you  for this very very wonderful honor